I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。
Hello. Hi, how's it going? It's going real, real well. Office, ladies. ["The Office Lady"] Hello. Hi, how's it going? It's going real, real well. I know. Should we tell everyone why we're so excited today? Yes, you tell everybody. I will tell you.
你好。嗨，最近怎么样？真的，真的非常好。办公室辣妈。["办公室辣妈"] 你好。嗨，最近怎么样？真的，真的非常好。我知道。我们要不要告诉大家我们今天为什么这么兴奋？对，你告诉大家。我来告诉你们。
We are very excited for today's episode because we have such an awesome guest. It's the very talented Jake Lacey, who plays our new favorite character Pete aka Plop. Yes! You guys know how much we've been loving this Pete and Erin storyline. We're rooting for Pete and Erin but really it is Jake's performance that has made us fall in love with this whole storyline. How can you not root for Pete? I love Pete! We love Pete. Many of you know Jake from the
我们对今天的节目感到非常兴奋，因为我们迎 来了非常棒的嘉宾。他就是才华横溢的杰克·莱西，他饰演我们新喜爱的角色皮特，也就是普洛普。耶！你们知道我们有多喜欢皮特和艾琳这条故事线。我们支持皮特和艾琳，但真正让我们爱上这条故事线的是杰克的表演。你怎么能不支持皮特呢？我爱皮特！我们爱皮特。很多人通过……认识杰克
office but he has gone on to work on so many awesome shows. I mean, Jenna and I, we both loved him in White Lotus. Lady, when we were trading emails with him, I waited until like the fourth reply, but I had to bring up White Lotus because I told him, Lee and I have an inside joke now from White Lotus, pineapple room. Oh yeah, you want the pineapple room. I told him, Lee and I have an inside joke now from White Lotus, Pineapple Room. Oh yeah, you want the Pineapple Room.
《办公室》，但他后来参与了那么多精彩节目的演出。我是说，詹娜和我，我们都很喜欢他在《白莲花度假村》里的表现。辣妈，当我们和他通过邮件交流时，我忍到第四封回复才提起《白莲花度假村》，因为我告诉他，李和我现在有一个来自《白莲花度假村》的内部笑话，菠萝房。哦对，你想去菠萝房。我告诉他，李和我现在有一个来自《白莲花度假村》的内部笑话，菠萝房。哦对，你想去菠萝房。
We're always like, I wonder where the Pineapple Room is at this hotel, who got the Pineapple Room? You sit by the pool, you're like, I wonder who has the Pineapple Room. And you know, you guys, you can also see him in High Fidelity, the series, Significant Other, A Friend of the Family, and so many more. And now you can catch him in his new show, Apples Never Fall.
我们总是说，不知道这家酒店的菠萝房在哪里，是谁拿到了菠萝房？你坐在泳池边，就会想，不知道谁住了菠萝房。你知道吗，大家还可以在剧集版《失恋高保真》、《同床异梦》、《家人的朋友》以及更多作品中看到他。现在你还可以在他的新剧《韦科惨案》中看到他。
This guy is super busy and we were so happy to finally catch up with him. He's such a funny and lovely person. He is an absolute delight. So we're going to take a quick break and when we come back, please enjoy our gosh. Jake is here. Hey, hey, hey. Thanks for having me. Thank you. It's so good to see you. We're so excited to be in touch with you. And I feel like we should say upfront that we have fallen in love with Pete. Yes, on the office. We are fans. We love you. Thank you. We love we love him. Oh my gosh. This is like exciting for me as a fan of Pete to have you here today. But you know what I mean, like, because of my insane, like, I don't know, relationship to the office
这家伙超级忙，我们很高兴终于能采访到他。他是一个非常有趣和可爱的人。他绝对是一个开心果。所以我们要稍作休息，回来后，请欣赏我们的天哪。杰克来了。嘿，嘿，嘿。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢。很高兴见到你。很高兴能联系到你。我觉得我们应该坦白说，我们已经爱上了皮特。对，在《办公室》里。我们是粉丝。我们爱你。谢谢。我们爱，我们爱他。噢天哪。作为皮特粉丝的我今天能请到你，这让我觉得好兴奋。但你知道我的意思，因为我对《办公室》那种疯狂的……
and that role and you go all in. Yeah, that's a crazy thing to hear. So thank you very much. I really appreciate that. That's nuts for me. Well, it's because you do such a great job playing him. We're all rooting for Pete. Like, Jenna and I are like, get out of here, Andy.
以及那个角色的感情，你全力以赴了。是的，听到这个感觉太疯狂了。所以非常感谢。我真的很感激。这对我来说太疯狂了。嗯，那是因为你把这个角色演得太棒了。我们都支持皮特。就像，詹娜和我一直在说，离开这里，安迪。
Let Pete and Erin be together already. Can he live? He just wants her to be happy, guys. He just wants her to be fulfilled, you know? I know. All right, so before we might have to, like, pause on our Pete adoration, Jenna, and get to the actual interview part. Yes, well, let's start from the beginning.
让皮特和艾琳在一起吧。能让他活命吗？他只是想让她快乐，伙计们。他只是想让她感到满足，你知道吗？我知道。好吧，所以在我们可能不得不，比如，暂停对皮特的爱慕之前，詹娜，我们进入真正的采访环节吧。好的，那我们从头开始。
We always ask people, how did you get your job on The Office? Well, you know what? I listened to the episode you all did of The New Guys, which was informative to me about what the casting process was outside of my little silo within it. You know, like, I didn't know they saw that many people for it, or I didn't know that saw that many people for it or I didn't
我们总是问大家，你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？嗯，你知道吗？我听了你们做的关于“新人”那一集，这让我了解了在我那个小圈子之外的选角过程是怎样的。你知道，比如，我不知道他们为这个角色试镜了那么多的人，或者我不知道他们试镜了那么多的人，或者我……
know that there was the potential for the show to continue on and that Clark and I would be, I don't know, a large part of that or something, you know? But you know what? I'd done a pilot for Fox that I desperately wanted to do. They replaced me with TJ Miller and I was like, that's it. I'm done. Like I'm never, career's over. That's that. What was the pilot, Jake?
不知道这个节目有继续下去的潜力，而克拉克和我将成为其中的很大一部分，或者诸如此类，你知道吗？但你知道吗？我之前为福克斯拍过一部试播集，我非常想做。他们用TJ·米勒替换了我，当时我想，就这样了。我完了。就像我的职业生涯结束了。就这样吧。那是哪部试播集，杰克？
It was called the Goodwin Games. It ultimately ran for like six episodes on Fox. And the guys who did How I Met Your Mother, who are really wonderful, wonderful, wonderful people wrote it and produced it. And they were so generous to call and say like, hey, this is above our heads, but you're not moving forward with the show. You know, like they could have sent that through my reps or something, but they personally called to go, this sucks, we're really sorry.
它叫《古德温游戏》。它最终在福克斯播出了大约六集。制作《老爸老妈浪漫史》的那些人，他们真的是非常、非常、非常棒的人，编写并制作了它。他们非常慷慨地打电话来说，嘿，这超出了我们的控制范围，但你不会继续出演这个节目了。你知道，他们本可以通过我的经纪人或其他什么方式传达，但他们亲自打电话来说，这太糟了，我们真的很抱歉。
And I don't know, really nice guys. So it was totally, totally putting some humanity into this weird business. And so then I, you know, that was in the spring. And then in the, you know, late summer, my manager called me and was like, they're going to add two guys to the office and they've already, they've already added one. And I, I don't know, either in my like confidence or naivete or I don't know something Competence of youth I was like I'm gonna be the other one like that's it like I've got it. This is it This I like this is I'm gonna do it. It's gonna happen
而且，真的超级好人。所以这绝对是、绝对是给这个怪异的行业注入了一些人性。然后我，你知道，那是在春天。然后在，你知道，夏末，我的经纪人打电话给我说，他们要在办公室增加两个人，他们已经、已经增加了一个。然后我，我不知道，也许出于我的自信或天真，或者我不知道某种年轻人的能力，我想，我将成为另一个人，就是这样，就像我得到了。就是这样。这个，就像我要去做了。这会发生的
Not that that had any effect on the result But just I don't know that was this feeling where I was it was my favorite show, you know I was like, oh my god, I would give anything to be honest. And so then I auditioned in New York. And then they blew me out to LA to test. And I didn't know where you guys shot. I didn't know anything. And you know, so they drive you out to the valley. And I'm like, I don't know. I don't even know LA. Like I have no idea. So we get out there and there's like me and ten other guys who look like me a handful of dudes that I see pop up and stuff now all the time and always like kind of cheer for them and then you know they I guess great came
倒不是说这会对结果有什么影响，但只是，我不知道，那是一种感觉，这是我最喜欢的节目，你知道，我当时想，天哪，我愿意付出一切去出演。于是我在纽约试镜。然后他们把我飞到洛杉矶进行实景试镜。我不知道你们在哪里拍摄。我什么都不知道。你知道，他们把你车到山谷区。我想，我不知道。我甚至不知道洛杉矶。就像我完全不知道。所以我们到了那里，有我和其他十个长得像我一样的家伙，还有几个我经常现在到处看到他们冒出来并总是为他们加油的家伙，然后，你知道，我猜格雷特来了……
out introduced me to Dave Rogers said there, this is a very important person on this show. I was like, okay, great. And then they opened the door and I'm like in the bullpen. Oh my gosh. Like I didn't understand that it was the set. You tested on the set? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Did you test with like cameras rolling and everything?
出来把我介绍给戴夫·罗杰斯，说，这是这个节目中非常重要的人。我想，好的，太棒了。然后他们打开了门，我发现自己在办公区。哦天哪。就像我根本不明白那是片场。你在片场试镜的？对，对，对，对。你试镜时是开着摄像机什么的吗？
Oh, dude, I opened the door. Clark is like at his desk. You're in the annex? Matt's there like, yeah, both cam ops are up. And Greg is like, you know, Dave suggested we shoot the test like the show, and he could edit it together so I could see what it would look like. It wouldn't be me guessing from a tape in a room somewhere, and it wouldn't be you fumbling around on a folding chair. Like, you could just be in the space. Wow. me guessing from a tape in a room somewhere, and it wouldn't be you fumbling around on a folding chair.
哦，老兄，我一开门。克拉克就在他的办公桌前。你在附楼？马特也在那儿，没错，两个摄像师都在工作。格雷特就像是，你知道的，戴夫建议我们像拍剧那样进行试镜，他可以把它剪辑到一起，这样我就能看到它会是什么样子。而不是让我从某个房间里的磁带盲目猜测，也不是让你在折叠椅上笨手笨脚。就像，你真的置身于那个空间里。哇。让我从某个房间里的磁带盲目猜测，也不是让你在折叠椅上笨手笨脚。
Like you could just be in the space. Wow. Yeah, I mean, we should tell people that that was really unique for the office. That was my testing experience as well. But most test auditions are like in a conference room with a bunch of executives watching you read it, or it's never like they edit it together for you
就像你真的置身于那个空间里。哇。是的，我的意思是，我们应该告诉大家，这对于《办公室》来说是非常独特的。这也是我的试镜经历。但大多数试镜就像是在一个会议室里，有一群高管看着你读剧本，或者从来没有像这样为你剪辑在一起……
and create like a mini version of the real thing. That was totally office unique. And I didn't know that they did that for you as well. That's fascinating. You know what's blowing my mind too, Jake, is that you're a fan of the show. Like, I'm just trying to imagine you're a fan of the show. You're in a van going somewhere deep in the valley'm just trying to imagine, you're a fan of the show, you're in a van
并创造出一个真实版本的迷你版。这完全是《办公室》独有的。我不知道他们对你也这样做过。这太迷人了。你知道让我更震惊的是，杰克，你竟然是这个节目的粉丝。我只是在想象你是个节目的粉丝。你坐在一辆去山谷深处某个地方的面包车里……我只是在想象，你是个节目的粉丝，你坐在一辆面包车里
going somewhere deep in the valley, you pass a crematorium, a junkyard, you're like, where am I? Then you're in a room, a random room with all- Yes, am I auditioning or are they going to murder me at the end of this van ride? But then the mental like mind bend that you did, like you're just kind of in a room with other guys
去往山谷深处的某个地方，你经过一个火葬场、一个垃圾场，你会想，这是哪儿？然后你在一个房间里，一个有着所有——是的，我是在试镜，还是他们要在这次面包车之旅结束时谋杀我？但随后你做出了心理上的转变，就像你只是和其他长得像你的家伙待在一个房间里……
that look like you and then you open a door and you're on the set of one of your favorite shows. You're like, what? And now you're supposed to audition. And be just totally cool. Well and the audition was improv. Oh my gosh. The audition was improv of Clark.
然后你推开一门，发现自己身处你最喜欢的节目之一的片场。你会想，什么？现在你要去试镜了。而且要表现得非常酷。而且试镜是即兴表演。哦天哪。试镜是和克拉克一起即兴表演。
No, it was not. Stop it. Yeah, fully. Greg was like, great, we're going to just set this up. You guys are working. And Clark has found a, somehow is hacked into your Facebook account or something like that and is now is looking at pictures of your mom. Oh my gosh.
不，根本不是。别开玩笑了。是的，完全是。格雷特就像是，太棒了，我们这就开始布置。你们在工作。而克拉克发现，不知怎么入侵了你的Facebook账户或者诸如此类的东西，现在正在看你妈妈的照片。哦天哪。
And Clark just kept making like, you know, a lot of innuendo based jokes and talking about asking if my mom had had breast augmentation or if I'd grown up, you know, seeing these boobs all the time and things like that. And, and me trying to get work done and being sort of, you know, laughing and also put out by that this is my coworker. And then we, so just back to what you've just said. Yes. My mind was like, it was a lot to take in. That was a lot in that moment to go like, oh, this is the creator of the American version of this show and I'm on the set and I'm, you know,
然后克拉克就不停地开一些，你知道的，很多基于双关语的玩笑，并谈论着问我妈妈是否做过隆胸手术，或者我是不是从小到大，你知道的，一直看着这些胸部等等诸如此类的事情。而我则试图专心工作，一方面觉得好笑，另一方面又对我的同事是这样的人感到困扰。然后我们，回到你刚刚说的话。是的。我的脑子就像是，信息量太大了。那一刻有太多的信息需要消化，就像，哦，这是这个节目美国版的创作者，我在片场，而且我，你知道……
it just was like a lot. And then I tested with Ellie, then did more improv with Ellie. And then they said, okay, great. This is all on the same day? You went from Clark? It's all in 20 minutes, yeah. Then they just brought me from the annex out to the,
这简直太让人应接不暇了。然后我和埃利一起试镜，接着和埃利进行了更多的即兴表演。然后他们说，好的，太棒了。这一切都是在同一天进行的？你从克拉克那……这一切都在20分钟内完成，是的。然后他们把我从附楼带到了……
to reception. To the reception. Yeah. And now you're walking through the whole entire set. Yeah, just trying to not lose my mind. Also, I'm like 25, maybe 26, you know, like, maybe younger, maybe 25. Like I just, I don't know, I'm 38 now, I still would lose my mind.
前台。到前台。是的。现在你要走过整个片场。是的，只是努力不让自己崩溃。而且，我当时25岁，可能26岁，你知道的，也许更年轻，大概25岁。就像我不知道，我现在38岁了，我还是会崩溃。
You know, it's not that I've gotten cooler about it. How long after this audition day did you have to wait to get the role? Oh, I flew home like that afternoon, probably. And then that was on like Thursday. And then they called on Saturday night to say, you got it, but also we shoot Tuesday.
你知道的，并不是说我对这件事变得更酷了。在这次试镜日之后，你等了多久才拿到这个角色？哦，我大概那天下午就坐飞机回家了。然后那是周四左右。接着他们在周六晚上打电话来说，你得到了这个角色，不过我们周二就要拍。
So you'll need to fly out like tomorrow afternoon. So I drove into the city, my girlfriend, now my wife Lauren was like working and I drove in to be like, I've got it. I'm gonna fly to LA. Like this is, I'm gonna go to LA. Fly to LA for how long? For like months?
所以你得像明天下午一样飞过去。所以我开车进城，我的女朋友，也就是现在的妻子劳伦当时正在工作，我开车过去告诉她，我得到了。我要飞去洛杉矶了。就像这样，我要去洛杉矶了。去洛杉矶呆多久？呆几个月吗？
For 10 months. Like pack your bag. You leave tomorrow. How do you pack for that? Unsuccessfully, you know, poorly. Just like a duffel with like, two t-shirts and some running shoes. Great, I'm out.
持续了10个月。就像收拾行李。你明天就要出发了。你怎么为这个收拾行李？没收拾好，你知道的，一团糟。就像一个随身行李包里塞了两件T恤和一双跑鞋。太棒了，我要出发了。
Like a go bag, but for a person who's like never served in the military. So your first time walking on set was actually during your audition, but do you remember what your first scene was after you got the part? Yeah, yeah, it was the slacklining and John kept breaking.
就像一个应急包，但是是为一个从来没服过兵役的人准备的。所以你第一次走进片场其实是在你试镜的时候，但你还记得你拿到角色后的第一场戏是什么吗？对，对，就是走扁带的那场，然后约翰一直在笑场。
And I was standing next to him and was so again this is as if a person even though I'm like I've gone to drama school I've been on one show previously I you know this is still like winning something off of a radio program for me you know like just some goof walking on set being like I'm a part of it for the day. And I'm standing next to John who keeps laughing, who keeps breaking while Rain is on the slackline. And I remember both Dwight is supposed to be getting
我当时站在他旁边，所以——再次说明，这就好像一个人，尽管我去过戏剧学校，我之前演过一个剧，你知道的，这对我来说仍然像从广播节目中赢了什么奖一样，你知道吗？就像一个傻小子走进片场，心想我今天也是其中一员了。我站在约翰旁边，他一直在笑，雷恩在走扁带的时候他一直在笑场。我记得德怀特本来应该表现得
more intense, but also Rain is slowly getting more frustrated with John laughing because it's really difficult to do the fake bad slacklining. And so it's both like the storyline is escalating and also this like friendship tension is escalating and I'm new and dying laughing. Like can't stop. I'm like, I'm going to get fired like day one.
越来越紧张，但同时雷恩也慢慢开始对约翰的笑感到沮丧，因为要做那种假装走得很烂的扁带真的很难。所以既有剧情的升级，也有这种朋友之间的紧张关系的升级，而我是个新人，笑得要死。根本停不下来。我想，我第一天就要被开除了。
You know what I mean? Like we won't get through the first scene and they're like, this kid can't stop. I'm like, I'm gonna get fired like day one. You know what I mean? Like, we won't get through the first scene and they're like, this kid can't, he's got 40 minutes to the day. I mean, like, come on, you know? And then the next day, I think the next was like a conference room. And it was like, I don't know,
你知道我的意思吗？就像我们第一场戏都拍不完，他们会觉得，这小子停不下来。我想，我第一天就要被开除了。你知道我的意思吗？就像我们第一场戏都拍不完，他们会觉得，这小子不行，他离当天收工还有40分钟呢。我是说，拜托，你知道吗？然后第二天，我想接下来是一场会议室的戏。大概是，我不知道，
Oscar had some line that kept getting me and I just kept having to like look away a lot. And I was like, I'm, you know what I mean? Like, I'm just, this is it for the next 20 episodes. I'm not going to ruin it. In rewatching this with my teenagers, there was a line, I can't even remember what it is, but Meredith comes for you so hard. Meredith hits on you a lot. And there's a few moments I'm like, I don't know how he got through that. There's some in the, you know,
奥斯卡有句台词总是让我笑场，我只能不停地把视线移开。我就想，你知道吗？这就是接下来20集的常态了。我不能把它搞砸。我和我的青少年们一起重温这部剧时，里面有一句台词，我甚至记不清是什么了，但梅雷迪思对你发起猛烈追求。梅雷迪思经常对你调情。有好几个瞬间我在想，他到底是怎么挺过来的。有些在，你知道的，
they're at the table in the snack room, break room. In the break room, yeah. Yeah, and she's right up on me a couple of times, like full body on me, you know? And it's so funny, it's so funny. We have to talk to you about a few sort of big epic office episodes that are legendary with the cast. And one of them is Work Bus.
他们坐在零食间、茶水间的桌子旁。在茶水间，对。对，她有好几次直接贴到我身上，整个身体都贴在我身上，你知道吗？太搞笑了，太搞笑了。我们得跟你聊聊《办公室》演员们口中那些史诗级的、传奇般的剧集。其中一集就是《工作巴士》。
Work Bus. Yes. What do you remember about Work Bus? Oh boy. Well, the like behind the scenes, well, BTST or just like the episode. Well, you know, we all called it Death Bus. Yeah. I remember Bryan Cranston directed that episode
《工作巴士》。是的。你对《工作巴士》有什么记忆？哦天哪。幕后花絮，还是就单指那一集？好吧，你知道的，我们都叫它“死亡巴士”。是的。我记得布莱恩·克兰斯顿导了那一集
and I remember the fumes. I remember there was almost no air conditioning that even when it was on it would be on for like 20 seconds as we did a turn around. You're like, that's not long enough to cool off a bus full of 20 people. I remember the fumes from, you know, because it's on a trailer or whatnot, the fumes billowing in and that being a real issue. I remember being on the road and timing out when things happen, because you had to get the same background on each side as you kind of cross covered people. That was a high bar too clear. Jake, I'm pretty sure too, when we did that big swerve,
我记得那些尾气。我记得几乎没有空调，即使开着也只开个20秒，当我们要换机位的时候。你会觉得，这根本不够时间给一车20个人降温。我记得那些油烟，你知道的，因为它拖挂在拖车上什么的，油烟滚滚涌进来，这成了一个真正的问题。我记得在路上行驶时要掐准事情发生的时间，因为当你从两边交叉拍摄时，每边都需要相同的背景。这也是一个很高的门槛。杰克，我很确定也是在那次大转弯的时候，
that's when you slid into me. And then I slammed into the wall, that window. Yeah. Are we sure that was me? I mean, that could have been any man. Yeah, that sounds right. Anyone on the bus. Was it you?
那是你滑向我的时候。然后我撞到了墙上，撞到了窗户。是的。我们确定那是我吗？我是说，那可能是任何人。是的，听起来没错。车上的任何人。那是你吗？
Somebody hit their head on that turn? Someone's head hit the window? There was a moment of... It was me. I hit my head. Look, years later, my deepest apologies. This is gotcha journalism. Have I been brought on to be shamed
有人在那次转弯时撞到了头？有人头撞到窗户上了？有一个瞬间……是我。我撞到了头。听着，多年以后，我致以最深的歉意。这是钓鱼执法吗？我被请来是为了
for propulsion of body sliding across seat? You have not, Jake. And we want you to know that Brian Cranston has gone on the record discussing these calamities. They are well known. Ellie has gone on the record discussing these calamities. They are well known. Ellie has gone on the record about peeing her pants in the bus. It was a day.
因为身体在座椅上滑行而感到羞耻吗？并非如此，杰克。我们想让你知道布莱恩·克兰斯顿曾公开谈论过这些灾难。它们是众所周知的。艾丽也公开谈论过这些灾难。它们是众所周知的。艾丽曾在巴士上尿裤子。那真是一天。
I do remember, maybe it was John, maybe it was Ryan. We stopped at one point and they, one or both of them got off and were like, I'm not getting back on this bus until you sort this out. But there was a real moment of like, hey, it's not just actors complaining in here. There's, you should, this should be addressed. And then the other was,
我确实记得，也许是约翰，也许是瑞安。我们在某个地方停下来，他们其中一人或两人下车说：“在你们把这事解决之前，我绝不上这辆巴士。”当时确实有一种真实的时刻，就像是，嘿，这不仅仅是演员们在这里抱怨。这里有，你们应该，这应该得到解决。然后另一个是，
there was silence on that bus for a little while. And Ed from the back was like, 17 cast members of the office died today. And Ed from the back was like, 17 cast members of the office died today. Like just peppered it out there and everybody started laughing. Did his Tom Brokaw. That he did his Brokaw announcing
那辆巴士上沉默了一会儿。埃德从后排说了一句：“办公室的17名演员今天去世了。”埃德从后排说了一句：“办公室的17名演员今天去世了。”就像随口那么一说，然后大家都笑了。模仿汤姆·布罗考的声音
that like the entire cast had been killed in a traffic accident. And I was like, that's hilarious. Like that is so funny in this moment where everyone's like, I can't, I can't, I will not stand for that. You know, silently stewing that he was like, from the deep, deep back of the bus. That's awesome.
他用布罗考播报的腔调宣布整个剧组在车祸中遇难了。当时我就想，太搞笑了。在这个每个人都觉得“我不能，我不能，我绝不容忍这个”的时刻，大家都在生闷气的时候，他从巴士的最深处冒出这么一句。这太棒了。
Well, we remember work bus the same. That's really similar to our memories. This is a crazy question. I feel like I know the answer. Did you really grow a mustache for Movember, for the episode Movember or was that a fakey mustache? I have such a weak mustache. I'll grow like an Amish kind of, you know, chin strap overnight. But the one thing I pine for is like a proper, I would just live with a cool, sell-a-cruise mustache if I could. So no, I didn't, I didn't do it.
好吧，我们对工作巴士的记忆是一样的。这跟我们的记忆真的很像。这是一个疯狂的问题。我觉得我知道答案。你拍“Movember”那一集时，为了留胡子真的蓄了胡子，还是那是假胡子？我的胡子太稀疏了。我一夜之间只能长出那种阿米什人风格的下巴须。但我梦寐以求的是那种真正的，如果可以的话，我愿意留着酷炫的塞拉利昂风格胡子。所以没有，我没，我没有那么做。
They cut my hair, you know, just to maintain that men's bob that I had, and then used the ends of those clippings to make my own little rat stash that they taped on. They used your own hair clippings to make that mustache? Yeah, yeah. I mean, it's both like overkill and also real attention to detail, it's pretty cool.
他们剪了我的头发，你知道，只是为了保持我那个男士波波头，然后用那些剪下来的碎发做成我自己的小老鼠须，然后把它粘上去。他们用你自己的头发碎屑做了那撇胡子？对，对。我是说，这既有点小题大做，但也真的非常注重细节，挺酷的。
Yeah. Yeah. Also better than being like, I don't know, this is someone's hair and we'll just put it on. Oh. Oh, God, okay. I think you got the better deal than what Paul Lieberstein got
对。对。总比说，我不知道，这是某人的头发，我们就把它粘上要强。哦。天哪，好吧。我觉得你比保罗·利伯斯坦拿到的待遇要好，
because that was like a small woodland creature on his upper lip. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's got to be fake too, right? That's not, he didn't grow up. Oh, that was for sure fake. Okay. I have to ask you about all of those diehard scenes. I mean, I watched all the deleted scenes and there were so many, Jake.
因为那就像是一只小型森林动物趴在他的上唇上。对，对，对。那肯定也是假的吧？那不是，他不是自己留的。哦，那绝对是假的。好吧。我得问问你所有那些《虎胆龙威》的戏份。我是说，我看完了所有的被删减片段，里面有太多了，杰克。
It was physical too, like you were like rolling on the ground and standing up and it was amazing. Yeah, I had, you know, my girlfriend was in New York so I was in LA alone and had no kids or pets or responsibilities so that is all just like memorized. And I think, you know, as an indication of like my obsession sometimes with things, I think it had been lightly suggested, like here's some scenes that'd be fun for you to, you know, so we could pull clips from it.
而且还很有肢体动作，就像你在地上打滚然后站起来，太惊艳了。对，我有，你知道的，我女朋友在纽约，所以我独自在洛杉矶，没有孩子、宠物或责任，所以那些全都是硬背下来的。而且我想，你知道，作为我对某些事情有时会有执念的体现，我想当时有人委婉地建议过，这里有些场景你可以去发挥一下，这样我们可以从中截取片段。
And then I memorized the first like 40 minutes of that movie or something, you know, like the cadence of it, the thing. Also, personally, because I was like, I don't want anyone who loves Die Hard to watch this and be like, what is he doing? That's not what happens. You know? You had so much detail, like you would say a line and you'd go ring, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
然后我就把那部电影的前40分钟左右的台词全背下来了，你知道的，它的节奏，那种感觉。另外，就我个人而言，因为我想，我可不想让任何喜欢《虎胆龙威》的人看这个的时候觉得，他在干什么？事情根本不是这样的。你知道吗？你准备的细节太丰富了，比如你会说一句台词，然后配音：叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。
You're not going to come here. Ring, ding, ding, ding. I'm like, what is the ring, ding, ding, ding, ding? Is it the big fan? What is that? Yeah, I felt like, I. I'm like, what is the ring, ding, ding, ding? Is it the big fan? What is that? Yeah, I guess I built out a whole world. Yeah, I thought it would be really fun to go for it. Or whoever, I think also, again, like whoever wrote that episode
你不会来这里的。叮，叮，叮，叮。我就想，这个叮，叮，叮，叮是什么？是那个大风扇吗？那是什么？对，我觉得，我。我就想，这个叮，叮，叮，叮是什么？是那个大风扇吗？那是什么？对，我想我构建了一个完整的世界。对，我觉得全力以赴会很有趣。或者不管是谁，我觉得同样地，写那一集的编剧
had approached me and been like, you should go for it. Robert Padnick. He loves Die Hard. Yeah. He's brilliant. Oh yeah, He's amazing. When I watched all those deleted scenes, I was like, this was hours of memorization. You must have spent so many days on that. I would just be in my trailer, you know, in that parking lot, just watching Die Hard, like, I don't even know if it was on my phone. I'm trying to, maybe they gave me a DVD of it and I could like play it on the little thing in the trailer or whatever. But like, yeah. Yeah, genuinely hours and hours and hours.
曾找过我，对我说：“你应该全力以赴。”罗伯特·帕德尼克。他喜欢《虎胆龙威》。是的。他太才华横溢了。哦，对，他太棒了。当我看完所有那些被删减的片段时，我在想，这需要花好几个小时来背台词。你一定在那上面花了好多天。我就会呆在我的拖车里，你知道，在那个停车场里，一直在看《虎胆龙威》，就像，我甚至不知道它是不是在我的手机上。我想，也许他们给了我一张DVD，我可以在拖车里的小设备上播放它或者别的什么。但是，对。对，绝对是几个小时又几个小时又几个小时。
Well, it's fantastic for anyone out there that has the DVDs, I highly recommend watching all of Jake's performances outside of the episode that live in the deleted scene. Thank you. I'm like, it was my one chance deleted. Jake, I have this memory of you joining the cast for that final season. And there was a group of us who were so delighted to have new people there.
好吧，对于所有拥有DVD的人来说，这真是太棒了，我强烈建议大家去看看被删减片段里杰克在正片之外的所有表演。谢谢。我就想，这是我仅有的一次被删掉的机会。杰克，我对你加入剧组拍摄最终季有一段记忆。我们有一群人非常高兴能有新面孔加入。
It was like, you and Clark, I'm afraid we were annoying. I'm afraid like, because we had all talked to each other for eight full years. And now finally, there were some new people. And it was the most exciting thing, I would actually try to like not overwhelm you with talking your ear off because we were just I mean, the crew included there was not a new face for so long. I have to know, like, how was it for you? I, well, I've never thought of it in those terms. Like, I've, it's never crossed my mind to go, all right, you had almost 10 years of working with the same people for months
就像你和克拉克，我担心我们会让人烦。我担心，因为我们所有人已经整整互相聊了八年了。现在终于有一些新人了。这绝对是最令人兴奋的事情，我其实一直在努力不让你觉得我们太唠叨，因为我们只是——我是说，包括剧组在内，很久没有出现新面孔了。我必须知道，对你来说，那是怎样的体验？我，嗯，我从来没有从这个角度想过。我，这从未掠过我的脑海去想，好吧，你们已经和同一拨人一起工作了近十年之久。
and months. And like, the bond that that brings, you also go, man, it'd be nice to not know everyone's life story. Exactly. It's so nice to not know everyone's life story that I'm here with. Exactly. It's so nice to have a little mystery. Yeah. I, you know, at the time, I just thought I was just so consumed with like, you know, don't mess this up.
还有好几个月。而且那种因此建立起来的纽带……你也会觉得，天哪，不知道每个人的人生故事其实挺好的。没错。跟那些我不知道他们人生故事的人在一起，感觉太棒了。没错。有点神秘感真好。对啊。我觉得，当时我满脑子想的只是，你知道的，别搞砸了。
Don't be weird around these people. Don't, you know what I mean? Like don't fan out and get weird and you know, like just show up and do your thing and leave. Don't try to make it social. Don't, you know, like nobody's excited that you're here, Jake. Just do your thing. So it's funny years later to hear you go like, we were thrilled to have new people here. And that you were like, I'm going to play it cool because that's what I was doing. I was fully being like, I'm going to play it cool. I'm going to play it cool. Like, hey, it's nice to meet you.
在这些人面前别表现得太怪异。别，你知道我的意思吗？别像个疯狂粉丝那样举止怪异，你知道的，就是来做好你该做的事然后离开。别试图去社交，别，你知道的，没人会因为你来了而激动，杰克。做好你自己的事就行了。所以多年后听到你说“我们当时有新面孔来这里，超级兴奋”时，觉得挺搞笑的。而你当时的反应是“我要表现得酷一点”，因为我当时就是这么做的。我完全是一副“我要表现得很酷，我要表现得很酷，嗨，很高兴认识你”的样子。
As if I've never seen the show and didn't know it existed. Instead of like, I've seen every episode. It's my favorite program. You know what I mean? Oh my gosh. Yes. Okay. So I just watched the episode with my teens. We did a little bit of a office marathon last night and we watched the beginning of Moving On
就好像我从来没看过这部剧，都不知道它存在一样。而不是表现得像“我看过每一集，这是我最喜欢的节目”。你知道我的意思吗？哦天哪。是的。好吧。我刚刚和我的青少年孩子们一起看了那一集。我们昨晚办了个“办公室”马拉松，看了《继续前行》的开头部分
and Andy comes back and he's forgotten that your name is Pete. He just calls you Plop and he's like, Aaron is hooking up with some guy named Pete. You have a great moment where you're like, I think Andy has called me Plop for so long. He's forgotten my name is Pete. That runner was hilarious. Which is my name, Pete. Like I think then I now like I say it again to the camera crew basically to be like, that's me just in case you guys are also not caught up. I'm Pete. Yeah, that was, you know, is that, John Favreau directed one of
安迪回来了，他忘了你的名字叫皮特。他直接叫你“普洛普”（Plop），还说艾琳在和一个叫皮特的家伙交往。你有一个非常棒的时刻，你当时说，我觉得安迪叫我“普洛普”太久了，他已经忘了我叫皮特。那个包袱太搞笑了。也就是我的名字，皮特。就像我觉得我当时——现在——我又对摄影机组说了一遍，基本上就像是在说，“那是我，以防你们俩也没跟上剧情，我是皮特”。对，那是，你知道的，那是乔恩·费儒导演的
those, it might be that episode. Yes, he directed it. And then they made it two. They made it two parts, right. They made it two. Yeah. I loved working with him. It was like, maybe my favorite big name guest director
其中一集，可能就是那一集。是的，是他导演的。然后他们把它做成了两集。他们把它做成上下两部分了，对吧。做成了两集。对。我很喜欢跟他合作。他就像是我除了哈罗德·雷米斯之外，
that we had outside of Harold Remus was Jon Favreau. And I know, I'm sorry, that was before he joined us. Yeah, he's a hero. Legend. But Jon Favreau was amazing. And so his episode was so good that they didn't want to cut a single minute from it and so they made it super sized. Yes.
遇到的最喜欢的名导之一，就是乔恩·费儒。我知道，抱歉，那是在他加入我们之前。对，他是我的偶像。传奇人物。但乔恩·费儒太棒了。所以他的那一集拍得太好了，他们一分钟都不想删，于是就做成了超长版。是的。
So, yeah. What I remember that he, well I guess I have a couple things. One is like I remember before every scene he would just go over the moment before. Yes. He would just as a group go like, hey, That he would just, as a group, go like, hey, just to be clear, this person's back. You're feeling this way about it. Maybe you guys feel something else about it.
所以，对。我记得他，嗯，我想我还有几点印象。一个是我记得在每场戏开拍前，他都会把之前的剧情梳理一遍。是的。他会把大家聚在一起说：“嘿，”他会以团队的形式说：“嘿，为了清楚起见，这个人回来了。你现在的感受是这样的。也许你们对这件事还有别的看法。”
I don't know, that's up to you. And you're worried about this. And earlier, we found out about that. So let's just keep that in mind. And go ahead. You know, like that clarity, just going back to the basics of like, where are you coming from? Where are you going?
“我不知道，这取决于你们。而且你很担心这个。之前，我们发现了那个。所以让我们把这些记在心里。开始吧。”你知道的，那种清晰度，就是回到基础上来：你从哪里来？你要去哪里？
What are you trying to get? Yeah, just good scene work. He was so good with that. Yeah, and letting that add up to something, you know, that if you had all the pieces, then in the edit, he could go, oh, I'll build it from here, you know? And also that he knew story wise there was something where I come in talking to Aaron, I'm asking about mail, Andy's back,
你到底想得到什么？是的，就是优秀的场景演绎。他在这方面太厉害了。是的，让这些累积成某种效果，你知道的，如果你掌握了所有碎片，那么在剪辑时，他就可以说，“哦，我就从这里开始构建”，你知道吗？而且他还从故事层面上知道有些地方可以调整——比如我进来跟艾琳说话，我在打听邮件的事，安迪回来了，
and there was some kind of back and forth like two or four or five lines, something like that. And John was like, just I know what they're trying to do here. I don't think this really accomplishes it. Just come in and look through the mail and look down to Ellie and she'll sort of look up to you and you can smile and then just take your mail and go to the desk. And I was like, amazing. Like that he understood to go like,
然后有一些两句、四句或五句台词的来回拉扯，诸如此类。乔恩就说：“我明白他们在这里试图做什么了。我觉得这样并不能真正达到效果。你只要走进来翻看邮件，然后抬头看一眼艾莉，她会稍微抬头看着你，你可以笑一下，然后拿上邮件走到办公桌前就行了。”当时我就想：太棒了。他居然懂得去想：
you maybe don't need this dialogue. Like, just we get it. We see two people who are into each other. We see this little quiet, private connection. And like, that means more to the story and to the audience than being quippy with each other. Like, that's not actually the thing that those two characters have found in each other
你可能不需要这些台词。就像，我们懂的。我们看到两个对彼此有好感的人。我们看到了这种安静、私密的联系。而且，比起互相抖机灵，这对于故事和观众来说更有意义。因为这其实并不是这两个角色在彼此身上找到的东西——
It's not a sparring partner. It's someone that they like to be with so just be with them You know like he could see that stuff go man, and I feel like I'm talking a lot But I just love the show and I don't know this is like a door to memory lane that I didn't know existed So it's very exciting Keep it up. You know he's't know existed. So it's very exciting. No, I know that. But I know Ed. Keep it up. You know, he's like, he finds out that it's me that Aaron has been seeing.
这不是棋逢对手，而是他们喜欢与之相伴的人，所以只要去享受那种陪伴就好。你知道吗？他能看出这些门道，然后说：“天哪，我觉得我话有点多，但我就是太爱这部剧了，而且我不知道，这就像是一条我以前不知道它存在的通往回忆的时光隧道，所以这太让人兴奋了。继续加油。你知道的，他——”等等，我不知道它存在。所以这太让人兴奋了。不，我知道。但我认识爱德。继续加油。你知道的，他发现原来是我和艾琳在交往。
And now is trying to drive this wedge. And I think there's outtakes of it where he's going through Wikipedia or like, you know, WebMD or something and it's going, yeah, you know, you never know who has what. I just got my test back and I've got, and looks over at the screen and then calls Chlamydia Chlamydia because he doesn't know what it is. And, but I didn't know he was going to do that and I just like lost it.
现在正试图在中间挑拨离间。我想有些删减片段是这样的：他在翻阅维基百科，或者像，你知道的，WebMD（美国医疗网站）之类的东西，然后说，“是啊，你知道的，你永远不知道谁会得什么病。我刚拿到检测报告，我得了……”然后看着屏幕，把衣原体（Chlamydia）叫成“施衣原体”（Shlamydia），因为他根本不知道那是什么。而且，我当时并不知道他会这么演，我直接笑崩了。
I just died laughing at him improv-ing. Shlamydia. That makes it in the episode too. Yes, then we had to go back and John was like, do it again, do that, do that, do that. And had been like, that was another one where he was like, don't worry about the dialogue, like let's just do one where you come in and you know that he knows and he knows that you know that he knows and let's see what happens. And so then there's like my proudest performance moment on that whole show is me going like, you know, you were gone, like now admitting it and trying
我当场被他即兴发挥的笑话给笑死了。施衣原体。这也被剪进正片里了。对，然后我们得重拍，乔恩就说：“再来一遍，就这样，就这样，就这样。”爱德也是那种情况，乔恩当时说：“别管台词了，我们拍一条这样的：你走进来，你知道他知道了，他知道你知道他知道了，让我们看看会发生什么。”于是，整部剧里我最引以为傲的表演时刻就诞生了——我走过去说：“你知道的，你之前不在……”现在承认了这一点，并试图
to deal with him and that he's like, I knew it, you know, like that it explodes into this thing. And that was this semi-organic like improv from John and Ed and that I was like, oh, this, wow. You know, again, as a fan and a love of the show and a participant and all this stuff, like coming together at once, you're like, oh my God, I can't believe I'm gonna do this. Like, yeah.
去应对他，而他的反应是“我早就知道了”，你知道的，这场戏直接爆发出了一种张力。那是来自乔恩和爱德的一种半有机的即兴发挥，当时我就想：“哦，哇。”你知道的，再次作为这部剧的粉丝、热爱者以及参与者，所有这些情绪同时涌上来，你会觉得：“哦天哪，我简直不敢相信我要演这个了。真的。”
Oh, that moment is so good. I didn't know that story behind that moment. It was brilliant. Oh, just all that, man. Yeah, God. So cool, dude. It's so cool. I just, yeah, man.
哦，那个时刻太棒了。我之前不知道那个时刻背后的故事。太精彩了。哦，所有这一切，天哪。是的，上帝。太酷了，老兄。太酷了。我就是，是的，老兄。
Makes me so happy to be thinking about it. I just wanted to know if there were, because you were just talking about opening that door to memory lane. Are there any other like scenes or moments or it could be an on camera and off camera moment that come to mind that we haven't talked about? Anything that like if you could go back and relive it, that you'd be like, oh, I gotta do that again? Oh.
一想到这儿我就觉得特别开心。我只是想知道，因为你刚才提到打开通往回忆的那扇大门，还有没有其他什么场景、时刻——可以是镜头前的，也可以是幕后的——是我们还没聊到、让你记忆犹新的？有什么事情是如果你能回到过去重温一次，会让你觉得“哦，我一定要再演一次”的吗？哦。
I bet there's a hundred that I, you know, I don't know, can't remember, or I don't know, but the ones I do are like, you know, your final talking head. Like, I think that I have a photo, I think, that I was even like, I should not be taking this. But like, I think it's- We were all in Video Village, Jake.
我敢说有一百个我都，你知道的，我不知道，记不清了，或者我不知道，但那些我记得的，比如，你最后的那段单人访谈（Talking Head）。我想我有一张照片，当时我还觉得，我真不该拍这个。不过，我觉得那是——我们当时都在视频村（Video Village，监视器区域），杰克。
Remember, we were all on that couch together watching it. Yes. Yeah. And I felt like I should not be here. Like, this is, these people have created this thing, and I got to like, be a bandaid on this, you know, like I'm a snail stuck to the side of the ship,
记得吗，我们当时都坐在那张沙发上一边看一边……是的。对。而且我觉得我不应该呆在那里。因为，这些人创造了这一切，而我来到这里就像是给它打了个创可贴，你知道的，就像一只黏在船舷上的蜗牛，
but these folks built the ship, you know, and going like, I should give them space. As if like a loved one was passing and I was, I don't know, someone bringing in Jell-O that was like, whoops, my bad. But I just remember being in that room and thinking like, this is nuts. Again, like as a participant, as a person on the show
但这些人建造了这艘船，你知道的，当时我就想：我应该给他们留点空间。就好像某个挚爱的人离去了，而我却是个，我不知道，带着果冻走进病房然后说“哎呀，不好意思”的人。但我只记得当时坐在那个房间里心想：这太疯狂了。再次强调，作为一个参与者、一个剧组演员
and going like, oh man, I've loved my time here. It's so sad to think this is the end of it, you know? And also as a viewer, as a fan of the show for so many years to go, oh man, I can't believe I'm here. I'm inside the thing. I'm inside the mothership, like watching it happen. This is insane. And I'm here with everybody who's made this thing for almost a decade.
然后心想：“天哪，我太爱在这里的时光了。想到这一切就要结束了，真的很伤心，你知道吗？”而且作为一个观众、一个多年老粉，也会想：“天哪，我简直不敢相信我在这里。我身处其中。我身处母舰内部，亲眼看着它发生。这太疯狂了。”而且我和所有为这个节目付出近十年心血的人在一起。
You know what I mean? It was just surreal. Surreal then, surreal now. It's never, I don't know. But other memories, riding to the, you know, being in a van with everybody going to the last table read and the way they had that table read set up with the cameras so that execs could see it back. Everybody wanted to be a part of it, you know? And the, after we wrapped and then there was that kind of strange rap party and then the very cool rap party and Stephen Merchant being there and me reintroducing myself to Stephen Merchant, assuming he does not know who I am. Even though he's an EP on the show and he was like, yeah,
你知道我的意思吗？那种感觉太超现实了。当时超现实，现在也超现实。那种感觉永远，我不知道。但还有其他的记忆，比如坐车去……你知道的，和大家坐一辆面包车去参加最后一次剧本围读（Table Read），他们把围读现场布置得很好，架了摄像机，好让高管们能在后面看到。每个人都想成为其中的一部分，你知道吗？还有在我们杀青之后，有一个那种怪异的杀青派对，然后是那个非常酷的杀青派对，斯蒂芬·莫 merchant（Stephen Merchant）也在那儿，我还重新向斯蒂芬·莫 merchant作了自我介绍，心想他肯定不知道我是谁。尽管他是这部剧的执行制片人（EP），而他的反应是：“对，
no, I know, Jack. I've seen every episode. I hired you. I've seen the edits. I'm aware. Still to the end being like, oh, pleasure to meet you. He was like, yeah, no, we got it, we got it. So Jen and I both know moments on the show where we completely lost it and could barely regain our composure. Like we lost it.
我知道，杰克。我看过每一集。是我雇的你。我看过剪辑版。我知道你是谁。”直到最后我还是：“哦，很高兴认识你。”而他说：“对，没错，我们都懂，我们都懂。”所以珍娜和我都知道剧里有一些时刻，我们彻底笑场了，几乎无法保持镇定。真的彻底笑崩了。
And I know you said that you broke at the slackline, but was there any other moment where you completely lost it? There's a couple times where, there's a couple times in the conference room where I really felt like, oh God, I'm going to die here. This will be the end. But some of those were like, John, John one time was like, hey, watch this, Brian, make it go on too long. And Brian was like, got it. And then at the end, when the scripted scene has finished,
我知道你说过你在走扁带（Slackline）那一场笑场了，但还有没有其他什么时刻是你彻底笑崩的？有好几次，在会议室里有好几次，我真的觉得：“哦天哪，我要死在这儿了。这就是我的死期了。”但其中有些时候是这样的，有一次乔恩说：“嘿，看着点，布ライアン（Brian），把这句演得太久一点。”布莱恩就说：“明白。”然后最后，当剧本规定的戏份结束时，
you know, Brian as Kevin would just lob in another line or two, like just calling back to his own storyline to be like, but are we going to you know, and like each time it would just ruin me to be both like, this has been so funny as scripted and then someone just freewheeling and going like, I'm going to take over at the end here. I was like, that is so unbelievably funny to me. I think there's a lot like, I don't know. I don't know if there's one where I'm like, I don't know what are ones, what are the top ones? Do you have any from that season that you go this, I couldn't
你知道的，作为凯文（Kevin）的布莱恩会随口抛出一两句台词，比如回顾他自己的故事线，然后说：“但是我们要不要去……”诸如此类。每次都会把我彻底击溃，一方面觉得：剧本写得太搞笑了，另一方面又有人在自由发挥，说：“我来在最后接管这个结尾。”当时我就觉得：这对我来说简直好笑得难以置信。我觉得有很多这样的时刻，我不知道。我不知道有没有哪一次是让我觉得：我不知道，最顶级的有哪些？你在那一季里有没有哪一场让你觉得：这戏我没法拍了？
function? Well, I have one that's very fresh just because I just watched it. When Aunt Shirley slapped me, she really slapped me. And you can see me sort of like, I have to like bend over because I'm kind of shock laughing. like, oh, that really hurt. She really slapped me. Really got a handful there. Yeah. But so that was very fresh for me. But just the conference room, whenever we all had a moment,
嗯，我有一个印象非常深刻，纯粹是因为我刚看过那一集。雪莉阿姨（Aunt Shirley）扇我耳光的那次，她是真扇啊。你可以看到我有点像——我不得不弯下腰去，因为我是一边震惊一边笑。心想：“哦，那一下真疼。她是真扇啊。这一巴掌太瓷实了。”对。所以那对我来说印象非常深刻。但只要在会议室里，每当大家都有台词，
whenever we all had a line and it was just like zipping around the conference room, there was always that great energy. And we were confined in that tiny space and that added to it all day long being stuck in that space. That's usually when I broke the hardest. I just remember losing it a lot during the lice episode. Kate being so like defensive and then balls and the guilt that my character had over the whole situation. It just, I just remember laughing a lot during that episode.
每当台词在会议室里像连珠炮一样飞来飞去时，那种氛围总是好得无与伦比。我们被困在那个狭小的空间里，一整天都被困在那个空间里的事实也为这种氛围加分不少。那通常是我笑得最厉害的时候。我只记得在虱子那一集里我笑得不行。凯特表现得那么防备，然后还有那些蛋（balls），以及我饰演的角色对整件事情感到的内疚。我只记得那一集我笑得前俯后仰。
As you say that, like I had forgotten, oh, I guess now it reminds me, like Zach Woods came back for one episode maybe. And I was a fan of his from a distance. And then in the moment, people had been been like they don't really write stuff for him because he's so smart that he kind of has alts for himself you know and that they'd offered for him to be a writer on the show a handful of times and he was like no I want to perform like I don't I want to be able to do both and he came in and
听你这么一说，我都快忘了——哦，我想现在这让我想起来了，扎克·伍兹（Zach Woods）好像回来客串过一集。我以前就是他的远程粉丝。然后在拍摄现场，大家都在说他们其实不用怎么给他写台词，因为他太聪明了，他自己就能准备好各种备选台词，你知道的，剧组曾好几次邀请他当编剧，而他的回答是：“不，我想演戏，我不想，我想两样都能做。”然后他走进来，
we're in a conference room it's just there's four of us there. And he the things he had brought with him in his little like dialogue bag of tricks. I was like, holy sh**. Like it was both what he was presenting and then also if I could try to keep up with him for a moment, like so fast back into it. You know what I mean? To add to it, not cutting me down, but just to add into fast back into it. You know what I mean? To add to it, not cutting me down,
我们当时在会议室里，现场只有我们四个人。他随身带在小“台词百宝袋”里的那些东西……当时我就想：卧槽。这不仅是他呈现出来的效果，而且如果我能试着稍微跟上他的节奏——那种极快的节奏反弹。你知道我的意思吗？是顺着往下接，而不是打压我，只是顺着把笑话快速抛回来。你知道我的意思吗？顺着往下接，而不是打压我，
but just to add into the joke of it. You know, I was like, this is another level. You know, like this is something I wish I knew what magic trick is happening here. You know, like, yeah, God. I just think, oh, and I, sorry. I know it's, I'm a guest on the show, so you're asking me questions,
只是顺着把笑话的梗抛回来。当时我就觉得：这是另一个水平了。你知道的，这就像是，我真希望能知道这其中的魔法是怎么变出来的。你知道的，天哪。我只是在想，哦，还有我，抱歉。我知道这是，我是节目的嘉宾，所以你在问我问题，
so I feel like I'm talking a lot about me, but I have food poisoning during that episode, so I would go throw up in my trailer. I didn't know you could call into work, and then come shoot those scenes. So I look like kind of the pallid, you know, in some of those scenes, and then like go back to my trailer.
所以我感觉我好像一直在聊自己，但我在拍那一集的时候食物中毒了，所以我得去我的保姆车里呕吐。我以前不知道你可以请假不舒服，然后还能去拍那些戏。所以我在某些戏里看起来面色苍白，你知道的，然后演完就得跑回保姆车。
For the lice episode? And just be like, no, uh, no, for whatever episode Zach came back for. And he hires my ex-girlfriend to then work there. Yes, yes. Right. And sets us up as this love hate triangle thing. But that episode I had food poisoning, so I was very sick. And then also coming in
为了拍虱子那一集？然后就想：不，呃，不，是为了扎克回来的那一集。他在那一集里雇了我前女友来那里上班。对，对。没错。把我们设定成了这种爱恨交织的三角恋关系。但那一集我食物中毒了，所以我病得很厉害。然后还得强打精神，
and like no food in my system and kind of like uh and Zach just like throwing heat for an hour and me like giggling at a conference table and then being like if you'll excuse me. To go back into my trailer and be sick. But that's one where I couldn't stop laughing and I thought like I'm gonna ruin this for him. They won't be able to edit around me laughing. I sound wildly unprofessional in that way, but just thinking, like, this is too funny. I won't manage.
体内一点食物都没有，整个人状态“呃……”，而扎克在一旁火力全开输出了一小时，我在会议桌旁咯咯直笑，然后说：“不好意思失陪一下。”然后跑回保姆车去呕吐。但那是那种让我笑到停不下来的时刻，当时我还想：我要被他害惨了。他们根本没办法把我的笑场剪掉。我听起来极其不专业，但我当时满脑子都在想：这太搞笑了，我根本控制不住。
Do you think Pete and Erin ended up together? It's very vague in the finale. What were you playing? What was your decision? in the finale, what were you playing? What was your decision? That I think she moves on. Really? You don't think they end up together?
你觉得皮特和艾琳最后在一起了吗？大结局里拍得很含糊。你当时是怎么理解的？你是按什么情绪去演的？在大结局里，你是怎么决定的？我觉得她是向前看了。真的吗？你觉得他们没在一起？
No, but I think like, look, I haven't really stayed, maybe this is different for you, for me, when people go like, I'm still close with all my exes. I'm like, you're out of your mind. But okay. To me, I'm like, I think he and Erin genuinely like, stay close. You know, that they each like had this time together
对，但我认为，听着，我其实没有一直留在……也许这跟你不一样，对我来说，当有人说“我和所有前任都还是密友”时，我的反应是：你疯了吧。不过好吧。对我来说，我觉得他和艾琳真心实意地保持着紧密联系。你知道的，他们有过这样一段美好的共处时光，
and she also finds such deeper, I don't know, clarity and closure in the other storyline for her of like her birth mother and you know that I feel like Pete is like a part of her life that informs that a little but isn't like the guy. But in this great way that they actually stay close, that they actually stay like really good friends and it just isn't the thing. Like, that's kind of my hope for them. But I don't know, maybe, you know, maybe other people feel differently. We'll get mail. We'll get mail.
而且她在另一条关于她生母的故事线中，也找到了更深层的、我不知道、更清晰的解脱和释怀。你知道的，我觉得皮特是她生命中的一部分，这让她对人生有了更多感悟，但他并不是那个“真命天子”。不过以一种很棒的方式，他们实际上依然保持着紧密的联系，实际上依然是很好的朋友，只是没能走到一起。所以，这就是我对他们的期望。但我也说不准，也许，你知道的，其他人有不同的看法。我们会收到听众来信的。我们会收到信的。
He's wrong. Oh, please. We also always ask people, do you get recognized for being Pete? And in your case, what do people call you, Pete or Plop? Yeah, it's Plop. Plop for sure. Plop, definitely. Aw. Yeah, aw, to an extent.
他猜错了。哦，拜托。我们通常也会问大家：你走在路上会被认出是皮特吗？对你而言，大家是怎么叫你的，叫你皮特还是普洛普？对，是普洛普。绝对是普洛普。普洛普，肯定的。啊。对，啊，某种程度上是这样。
It is, you know, you go, better than not being recognized, you know what I mean? That's very nice. But also like, Oh great. It's the difference that someone goes like, did you plop on the office? And you go, yeah, man, that's me, totally. Or when like at Home Depot, someone's like, plop.
这，你知道的，你会想：总比没人认出来强，你知道吗？这挺好的。但有时也会觉得：哦太好了。区别就在于，有人走过来问：“你在《办公室》里演普洛普吗？”然后你回答：“对啊，老兄，那就是我，完全没错。”或者当你在家得宝（Home Depot）买东西时，有人大喊：“普洛普！”
You're like, hey man, hey bud, would not yell that, you know, like that's, that's what I'm saying. You know, like it just is that variation of the interaction because ultimately like it's not the name, it's just like one feels like a human interaction and one feels like, I don't know, weird. But yes, it's sometimes Pete, sometimes Pete.
你就得说：“嗨，老兄，嗨，兄弟，能不能别在大街上喊这个，”你知道的，这就是我的意思。你知道的，这就是互动中的各种变体，因为归根结底，名字不重要，只是有些互动感觉像正常的人际交流，而有些则感觉，我不知道，怪怪的。不过是的，有时叫皮特，有时叫皮特。
Everyone's well, I get green is horish. And I'm like, can we dial that one down folks? We can put that one to bed gang. That's all right. My kids are here. I don't need to explain what horish means. Thank you. To an entire middle school.
时不时地，我还会听到有人喊“真好色”（horish）。我就想：大家能不能把这个词收敛一点？各位，咱们别再用这个词了行吗？没关系。我的孩子们就在这里。我不需要解释“好色”是什么意思。谢谢。当着一整所初中的面。
Like what the, come on guy. Did you take anything from set when it wrapped? Cause we all took a little something. I was too afraid. Too afraid. Too afraid. I know now that's like I should have just like brought a duffel bag and been like, it's all mine.
这算什么，行了吧各位。杀青的时候你从片场拿走什么纪念品了吗？因为我们每个人都多多少少顺了一点。我当时太怂了。太怂了。太怂了。我现在知道了，当时我应该直接带个大duffel包（行李袋）去，然后说：“这些全都是我的了。”
I'm taking it. No one will know. No, I was sure that I'd get a call and people would be like, did you take the stapler from there? Oh, no, I think I maybe have like a script, maybe like a final script, something like that. All right.
“我要拿走了。没人会发现的。”不，我当时坚信自己会接到电话，然后有人会质问：“是不是你把那里的订书机拿走了？”哦，不，我想我大概留了个剧本，大概是一个最终版剧本之类的东西。好吧。
I wanted to share with you that we noticed we have all the call sheets because everyone's been so amazing since Jenna and I started this podcast. They have just shared with us shooting drafts and candy bag alts and call sheets. So we've really been able to dig in, you know? And one of the things I noticed on the back of the call sheets for season eight, they've actually stopped for season nine, I'm not sure why, but on the back of the call sheets for season eight, there was a little section where it was like get to know your cast and crew. And they picked a person and asked them five questions. And it was on the back of every call sheet. And I am loving them because the questions are
我想跟你分享一件事，我们发现我们拥有所有的通告单（call sheets），因为自从我和珍娜开始做这个播客以来，每个人都太好了。他们跟我们分享了拍摄剧本、糖果袋备选台词还有通告单。所以我们真的能够深入挖掘很多幕后细节，你知道吗？我注意到第八季通告单的背面有一件事——到了第九季他们其实停用了这个，我不知道为什么——但在第八季通告单的背面，有一个小板块叫做“了解你的演职人员”。他们会挑选一个人，问他五个问题。每一张通告单的背面都有。我太喜欢这些内容了，因为这些问题简直
fantastic. And we asked these to Brian Cranston and I was like, Oh my gosh, Jenna, we have to ask these to every guest moving forward because these questions are so fun. So here they are. The first question is, what was your first entertainment job? Oh, well, the first like real professional, I was 16. Yeah, 16 or 17. And I grew up in Vermont, the Bread Loaf campus of Middlebury College in the summer would do a language program and they would also have people from theater in Providence come up and do shows so I was in Tom Stoppard's Acadia when I was like 16 I think 17 and you know it's just for the summer but was like working with professional actors and knew I wanted to be an actor at that point. So that was like my first ever.
太棒了。我们把这些问题问了布莱恩·克兰斯顿（Brian Cranston），当时我就想：“哦天哪，珍娜，我们以后得把这些问题问每一位嘉宾，因为这些问题太有趣了。”所以，问题来了。第一个问题是：你的第一份娱乐业工作是什么？哦，嗯，第一份真正专业的，我当时16岁。对，16岁或17岁。我在佛蒙特州长大，夏天时明德大学（Middlebury College）的布雷德洛夫（Bread Loaf）校区会举办语言项目，他们还会邀请普罗维登斯的剧团来这里演出。所以当我还大概16岁、17岁的时候，我就参演了汤姆·斯托帕德（Tom Stoppard）的《阿卡迪亚》（Arcadia）。我想，你知道的，那只是个暑期演出，但能和专业演员合作，从那时候起我就知道自己想成为一名演员了。所以那是我的第一份工作。
Oh, Jake, that makes my theater nerd hearts well so much. All right, I have the next question. Do you speak any other languages? No, language of the heart. No, I don't. I don't. I like I'm working on Italian, but it's not going quickly. So no, the answer is no. What was the goal in wanting to learn Italian? Was it I'm going to go there and I'm going to be like is what why Italian? I spent a very small amount of time there maybe 10 years ago and traveled around in
哦，杰克，这让我内心那个戏剧书呆子疯狂膨胀。好，我有下一个问题。你会说其他语言吗？不，只会说“心之语”。不，我不会。我不会。我喜欢——我正在学意大利语，但进展不是很快。所以，不会，答案是不会。当初想学意大利语的目标是什么？是不是想着“我要去那里，然后我要……”为什么是意大利语？我大约10年前在那里呆过很短一段时间，在
Italy and thought like, this is it. This is where I would move tomorrow, like any part of it. Tuscany, Umbria, down to the coast. I mean, like I just was totally taking with it. And you know, always honestly have one foot in going like, maybe I'll move to Italy. You know, like, I have kids now and married, whatever, but go like, let's go. Like this business is so remote. I rarely shoot in New York or LA anyways,
意大利到处旅行，当时就觉得：就是这里了。这就是我明天就会搬来定居的地方，无论这里的哪个部分。托斯卡纳、翁布里亚，一直到海岸。我的意思是，我完全被它迷住了。老实说，心里总有一只脚在盘算着：也许我会搬到意大利去。你知道的，现在我有了孩子，也结婚了，诸如此类的，但就会想：走吧。这行太远程办公了。反正我也很少在纽约或洛杉矶拍戏，
there's no reason for me to go like, I need to be a train ride away from the city is like, yeah, if I want to do a play, that's true. But the reality of mostly what my work is, is like sending in self tapes, meeting people over Zoom, you know, maybe an offer, but really that's kind of rare. So like, I could live anywhere and why not pick up and go to Florence? Why not go to Siena, you know? So, and if we were to do that, I'd like to be engaged in a culture
我没有什么理由非得说：“我需要住在离市区坐火车就能到的地方”——对，如果我想演戏剧话剧的话确实如此。但实际上我的大部分工作都是：发送自录试镜视频、通过Zoom开会，你知道的，也许偶尔能直接拿到角色邀约，但这种情况其实很少见。所以，我可以在任何地方生活，为什么不收拾行囊去佛罗伦萨呢？为什么不去锡耶纳呢，你知道吗？而且如果我们真的那么做了，我希望能真正融入当地文化，
and not just like an expat floating around the prototypical American to go like, anyone here speak English? English, anybody? But we'll see. Well, that folds into question number three on the call sheet is, what's a place you've been to
而不是像个到处游荡的外侨，表现得像个典型的美国游客，到处问：“这里有人说英语吗？英语，有人会吗？”但我们拭目以待。好吧，这正好切合了通告单上的第三个问题：你曾经去过哪个地方
that you loved. So I think that's for you, Italy. Italy, to be sure. And also, I mean, London, I don't know, I spent a little time in London. I thought this is, I would also, you know, it's the most expensive city maybe in the world. But London, I just thought was wonderful.
让你流连忘返？所以我想对你来说就是意大利了。意大利，肯定的。还有，我的意思是，伦敦，我不知道，我在伦敦呆过一段时间。我觉得这是——我也许会觉得这是世界上物价最高的城市吧。但伦敦，我真的觉得是个好地方。
Yeah. I don't know. I think that all wonderful. Yeah. I don't know. I think that all sounds pretty fantastic. I want to go. You know, I had friends in my 20s. Of course, they didn't have kids yet, you know, but they decided to go live in Italy for a year. And they went and they lived in Italy for a year
对。我不知道。我觉得所有这些听起来都棒极了。我想去。你知道的，我20多岁的时候有几个朋友。当然，他们当时还没孩子，你知道的，但他们决定去意大利生活一年。于是他们就去了，并在意大利生活了一年。
and they loved it. And I think they think back to that time in their life so fondly and I grew up overseas. So Jake, I'm saying go for it. Where did you grow up? Where were you overseas? I lived 12 years in Jakarta, Indonesia. Oh my god.
他们太喜欢了。而且我觉得他们对人生中的那段时光怀有深厚的感情，我是海外长大的。所以杰克，我说你就去吧。你在哪里长大的？你海外待在哪？我在印度尼西亚雅加达住了12年。哦天哪。
What was there that your family was there for? My dad was a drilling engineer. And he was transferred there in the 70s. And I grew up there. I loved that chapter of my life. And I think you just, it's such an education. So I don't want to get in trouble here. I don't want to step in your business with your wife, but I'm just saying.
你家人当时去那里是为了什么？我爸爸是一名钻井工程师。他在70年代被调到那里。我在那里长大。我很喜欢人生中的那段时光。而且我觉得，这真是一种教育。所以我不想在这里惹麻烦。我不想干涉你和你太太的事，我只是说说。
She's into it. She's like, let's go. Go for it. For real. Yeah, no, you're, you're tipping the scale. Well, if office ladies come to Italy, we will find you. You've always got a place to sit. You'll always be welcome in our house.
她很感兴趣。她觉得，我们走吧。去吧。真的。对，不，你，你正在让天平倾斜。好吧，如果Office Ladies来意大利，我们会找到你的。你随时都有座位。在我们的家里，你永远受欢迎。
Pasta and pool. Next question is, what do you like to do on the weekends? I mean, I've got two little boys, so it's, the weekends are not my own. Do you know what I mean? It's like when they're in school. Yeah. On the weekends, what my own. Do you know what I mean? It's like when they're in school. On the weekends, what do I really like to do? If I get the chance, I love running. I love trail running. If I can get away for just a little bit to do that or boy, reading. If I get like a half hour and I'm just reading, boy, that's a pleasure. You're so obviously the parent of small children.
意面和泳池。下一个问题是，你周末喜欢做什么？我是说，我有两个小男孩，所以，周末根本由不得我。你懂我的意思吗？就像他们上学的时候一样。对。在周末，我有什么属于自己的。你懂我的意思吗？就像他们上学的时候一样。在周末，我真正喜欢做的事是什么？如果有机会，我喜欢跑步。我喜欢越野跑。如果我能稍微抽空去做这件事，或者天哪，阅读。如果我能有半个小时只是阅读，天哪，那真是一种享受。你一看就是带小孩子的家长。
A shower? Because I remember these days. A shower, yes. An uninterrupted shower. Yeah. Okay, last question, Jake. What is your favorite midnight snack? Cold pizza.
洗个澡？因为我还记得这些日子。洗个澡，是的。一个不被打扰的澡。对。好吧，最后一个问题，杰克。你最喜欢的午夜零食是什么？冷披萨。
Yeah? Oh yeah? I'll order pizza, eat too much of it the first time, convince myself I won't have any later, put the kids to bed, put something on, be like, do you want a snack? My wife's like, I'm good, dude. I had too much for dinner. I'm like, yeah, no, totally. And then go downstairs and like make the coffee, let the dog out, eat two pieces of pizza. Be like, what are you doing? What is happening?
是吗？哦是吗？我会点披萨，第一次吃太多，说服自己待会儿不吃了，把孩子们哄睡觉，放点节目，然后说，你想吃点零食吗？我太太说，我不用了，伙计。我晚饭吃太多了。我说，对，没错，完全同意。然后下楼去煮咖啡，放狗出去，吃两块披萨。然后说，你在干什么？这到底是怎么回事？
So it's that and also man of late, frosted mini wheats has been like, they're just in there and I think, oh, that'll fill me up a little. It's a little sweet. It's a little whatever, you know? And like we have these poor tubs. It's not just the box, you know,
所以就是那个，还有，伙计，最近糖霜迷你麦片也一样，它们就在那儿，我想，哦，那能让我稍微填饱肚子。有点甜。有点别的什么，你知道吗？就像我们有这些大桶。不只是盒子，你知道的，
keeping it all real organized. But I won't like put it in a bowl because I'm convinced, you know, I'm convinced I'm going to have like two little hand pulls and that'll be that. But instead, I probably put away like half a bag of cereal and then go like, dude, it's midnight. Like, come on, bud. Also why run? You know what I mean? Just why run and go to the gym?
把它整理得井井有条。但我不会把它倒进碗里，因为我确信，你知道，我确信我只会抓两小把，那就行了。但相反，我可能会吃掉半袋麦片，然后说，老兄，现在都半夜了。拜托，伙计。话说为什么要跑步？你懂我的意思吗？为什么还要跑步去健身房？
Then from 11 to 12, you're going to do your own at-home fourth meal. You know, remember when Taco Bell made that a thing? They were just legit like, go ahead, have 25% more food than anyone's ever written. Fourth meal. Oh, all right, cool. Yeah, we'll do that. We're into it. That's very funny. Yeah, so that's pizza, pizza, roasted mini-wheats, and yeah. Nutritious. Super, you're packing in some extra nutrition.
然后从11点到12点，你要在家里吃第四餐。你知道吗，还记得塔可钟把这个变成潮流的时候吗？他们简直就像是，来吧，吃掉比任何人吃过的多25%的食物。第四餐。哦，好吧，太酷了。对，我们会这么做的。我们很感兴趣。这太有趣了。对，所以这就是披萨，披萨，糖霜迷你麦片，还有，是的。有营养。太棒了，你摄入了一些额外的营养。
I love not committing to a bowl though. That is me. I'm like, if I only take a few handfuls of M&Ms, is it really anything? Cause I didn't put it in a container. It's just a few. Right. And I double dip.
不过我喜欢不用固定用一个碗。那就是我。我想，如果我只抓了几把M&M巧克力豆，真的算什么吗？因为我没有把它倒进容器里。只是一小把。对。而且我不会重复蘸料。
And then like, yeah. Yeah. And then by October 10th, you're like, somehow we're out of candy for Halloween. I don't know how that happened, but. Wasn't me. I didn't put it in a bowl. Yeah, no, it's a problem. It was a problem.
然后，是的。对。然后到了10月10日，你会想，不知怎么的，我们万圣节的糖果没了。我不知道这是怎么发生的，但是。不是我。我没有把它倒进碗里。对，不，这是个问题。这确实是个问题。
Aw, Jake, it was so good to see you and get to reconnect. You are just the same. Just the same awesome guy. And this was really fun. Yeah, thanks so much. This was really lovely. Thank you for having me on here. And Jake, we just loved you on set.
噢，杰克，很高兴见到你并重新联系。你一点都没变。还是那个超棒的家伙。这真的很有趣。对，非常感谢。这真的很好。谢谢你邀请我来这里。杰克，我们在片场非常喜欢你。
You were just so wonderful to be around. And so I just hope you know how much we all just like, you just fit in seamlessly and you were just part of the family. That really means a lot. Thank you, thank you. This is like me then saying thank you and me now saying thank you, you know? Like it really, thanks. Thank you. Yeah, thank you.
和你在一起真是太美妙了。所以我只希望你知道我们有多么喜欢你，你完美地融入了进来，你就是这个大家庭的一部分。这真的意义重大。谢谢，谢谢。这就像当时的我在说谢谢，而现在的我在说谢谢，你知道吗？真的，谢谢。谢谢。对，谢谢。
Do you see what we're saying? How great is Jake Lacey? I know. Love him. I love him even more now. I know. Well, a big thanks him even more now. I know. Well, a big thanks to Jake for sharing with us about his time on The Office, and please be sure to check out his new show, Apples Never Fall, on Peacock.
你明白我们的意思了吗？杰克·莱西有多棒？我懂。爱他。现在我更爱他了。我懂。好吧，非常感谢他与我们分享他在《办公室》的时光，请务必在Peacock上观看他的新剧《苹果永不落地》。
Thanks so much for listening. We hope you have a good week, and we'll see you next time. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢大家的收听。我们希望你们过个好周，我们下期见。到时见。感谢收听Office Ladies。《Office Ladies》由Earwulf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击节目文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。